je pense qu'il peut être président parce
que ce qu'il a très bien compris et
d'ailleurs ce il le dit mais je le dis
aussi depuis des années c'est que en
2022 ça sera pas une élection
présidentielle ça sera la bataille de
france et pour la france est
le seul à l'avoir déjà vous qui feront
que je ne voterai pas pour ces gens-là
royère sait jamais ce que je vous
entends depuis tout à l'heure vous
parlait
il ya deux dames qui sont vraiment les
imitations ce suivi en le drame et vous
vous êtes là avec assurance d trop
d'assurance
est pas bonne et moi je vais être franc
avec vous l'avez déjà j'imagine je vais
être franc avec vous d'autant que c'est
comment mais vous êtes vous magasinez un
point
sépare de michel c mais je vais vous
dire à cause ou grâce avec l'appui des
gens je crois ce qu'on vous qui font que
jamais au grand jamais je ne voterai
pour une personne comme ceux sur cette
personne qui pour moi pour moi entendez
bien c'est une coquille vide
c'est écouter quand vous montrez le plan
que tu es et tu les coquilles vides
écoutez bien garnie des brèves de
comptoir voilà il a signé à cannes et je
suis bien placé des brèves de comptoir
l'un de mes
essais des brèves de comptoir avec qui
il a réalisé il a révisé son histoire
géo voilà et nous on est là à côté de
lui mais le truc on est mais il a raison
elle droit des calculs quand même et
vous nous prenez la syrie pour dire ça
vous avez déjà écrit des bouquins
des bouquets
célébrer
déjà le week end zemmour c'est qui le
gagne et c'est que ce qu'il gagne mais
vous avez déjà lu un bouquin de zemmour
bas une fois dans votre vie sanaa mais
c'est beaucoup d'accords
c'est déjà lui décrivent des émaux dont
le dernier il ya lien il ya
effectivement je peux confirmer qu'il ya
des conneries plus
je vais vous
le début de la soirée j'en crois le
jeune qui a fait un livre de science
comment on va plus en toute amitié
politique fiction multiples politique
fiction sur l'élection de de zemmour bon
ça c'est pour le livre dans la réalité
est ce que vous partagez la vie de jean
bessis as qui peut zemmour pour être le
prochain président de la cub et je pense
vraiment que et je lis à six mois je ne
pensais pas et si moi je trouvais que la
la les producteurs peuvent répondre si
moi j'ai trouvé que que que c'est bon
c'est moi n'est pas très bien que son
intention n'était pas très clair etc et
je dois reconnaître que ce qui se passe
depuis ce qui se passe depuis un mois
avec cette contrée politique absolument
hallucinante où le mec passe de 3% à 17
millions en même 18 de 1,4 confiant il
est bien aidé en même temps je peux
juste parler
c'est vrai qu'il a abusé du temps de
parole que j'occupe racontant à lire un
bouquin de zemmour pour comprendre ce
qu'il dit
est donc donc en fait moi pour plein de
raisons je pense que il a écrit deux
choses premièrement le vide idéologique
qui avait à droite entre leur assemblée
nationale qui ne réfléchit plus la
droite qui a arrêté de réfléchir la très
longtemps et le fait qu'il fallait
prendre l'espace entre les deux pour
aller taper dans les deux électorats
c'est exactement ce que rien ne se passe
et cercle hippique autant à bertrand cas
marine le pen est il en train de
construire son ascension sur un truc qui
en fait pour moi existe et est là depuis
10 ans 15 ans et que personne ne
réussissait à prendre et ensuite il ya
un autre truc kéké de l'ordre un peu de
l'irrationnel mais on a vu beppe grillo
en italie arrivé en politique et faire
un carton on a vu trump arrivé en aux
états unis et faire un carton et en fait
c'est un peu notre homme pas la
française au sens où il a la même façon
si la référence et être
oui mais pardon on va rester
très bien sûr c'est vrai faire une agent
fois et ce qui est intéressant c'est que
il ya le parler vrai qui fait de tous
ces gens
la dimension française qui est qui et
que un gros trump manche des burgers il
est assez vulgaire il est très américain
et zemmour il est très littéraire face à
eric tu sais ça par coeur avec beaucoup
de références et tout donc c'est une
version francisée de tout ça et moi je
trouve que la dynamique elle n'est pas
du tout inexplicable et contrairement on
compare beaucoup à chevènement qui a
fait 14 % dans les sondages puis 5-2 en
réalité il est assis sur un vrai truc
c'est à dire que ce que disent les gens
à l'instant sur la bataille de france
espèce de référendum en gros que zemmour
est en train d'imposer dans le débat
public pour ou contre l'immigration pour
ou contre l'insécurité etc tous ces
thèmes qu'il a réussi à mettre dans la
campagne aujourd'hui je pense le porte
de manière beaucoup plus forte que n'ont
été portés par le passé des gens qui ont
fait des percées dans des sondages comme
bayrou chevènement et qui après son seul
problème